hello gang
welcome back to Minecraft if you're
flowe against subscribe right now for
stealing gang cringed just stop making
me cringe wait wait wait okay I have the
electron yeah yeah yeah what's up if
you're new this is my best friend it's
Ben we make out it's it's okay stop
I don't even know who you are I don't
know where you came from and the way
this is my horse here again I love him
alright let me show you guys let me show
you guys I was thinking cuz you know
look here's the goal I made from last
episode I made so much gold oh I
couldn't make this on God now I'm stuck
I could uh it's fine I could make this
tower into like and I don't want to
forget my bros from the past from season
one of the anime I thought I could make
this into a tower of gold for my men so
this would be for Jurgen smirking one
this would be for year against Mergen
two they get one tower each let me know
if you have any ideas or designs and
I'll steal them so I also got accused of
cheating which is fair but now for the
reason you would expect some ones that I
was cheating because they fix zero tick
farms so this is impossible I know it
doesn't work it stopped working okay I
was collecting what I had already
connected but today we have a main big
mission isn't that right Willoughby
defeatist Mita listen to me how's it
going over here you're doing a good job
so far no no escape
what the hell shut up
alright we're heading out basically last
episode we found a bastion I think
they're called so there's this new
really cool structure in the game but
there's four different types of bastions
that can spawn and we only find one of
them so I'm really curious that shut up
my god
speaking to you you interrupt my
sentence stupid bit why was I my god
alright as always we have to pay our
taxes to Alabama
he loves wood there you go Thank You
Alabama for letting us tread on your
lands please bless us with a successful
journey across your your realm Thank You
Alabama thank you thank you he has
accepted the blessing hopefully we can
find the new areas that'd be cool
all right look at this Oh God
I was I got a little scared there for a
second so apparently they look so stupid
because they're cold
look at you you dumb you're so dumb all
right so we're gonna go this way this
time because the other time I went that
way so to make him go faster I get right
to click on him faster this is as fast
as he goes are you kidding me go away go
away
no no no no no no no god they're
following me stop ugly people can't come
all right cool I'm just gonna leave it
here I'm gonna head out a flora gang and
see where we end up is that dangerous -
just leave it I'm thirsty
you dumb no more
well well well boys look what could get
through alien it's not what we're
looking for but I'll take it I'll park
you here now you're absolutely useless
and you're ugly I don't like you you
have no friends you will never have any
friends just stay there okay thank you
appreciate it
god damn bar whoa look at them stupid I
guess you can farm them and every
thought oh they don't shoot the Swedish
man please oh never mind
I'm not looking for a nether fortress I
want nether bastions come on
Oh God let's not go there I say let's
keep going this way all right nice
another one Jesus dude we got epic speed
happening here wow there's so many
freaking pigs dude bye
oh damn so many here so much action here
we're cool right yeah I'm wearing boots
we're cool yeah yeah yeah we're cool
smell their Iceman go oh god I smell
death chief says oh what is that oh
that's one that's one that's one nice
yes baby yes
give me another right get Ned the right
net the right Smither right come on come
on
what now look with this are you kidding
me Golden Apple that's useless give me
the bowl yeah hey I'll say give me the
go oh yeah baby
sorry I'm sorry look at this look at it
Oh Bastion
where are you Sebastian no oh
found one found one what was huge
look at that oh my god it's my said it's
so big
Oh oh god it's so big oh god I got a
says I almost flipping globe or duped I
feel like top and we work our way oh god
oh god oh god
stop this okay perfect nice it begins I
have an axe for some reason NASA for god
dammit i'ma put on the armor oh well
well well what we have down there I
think I will grab you that's a lot of
gold hey we're cool right I recall I
can't tell dude they spoil you with the
bastions if you manage to finally look
at that this is the same as the other
one it's just bigger hopefully we can
get better loot this time I don't want
to go we're gonna build the whole
factory of gold all I want
screw diamonds screw in there the right
I don't even want it oh sorry I need to
stop doing that's really annoying I know
it's just so much fun does it go alright
hey bruh hey bruh bruh can you no longer
push these get oh god I made a mistake
he asked for it I swear to God he told
me to do it
he pulled me to do it you didn't see
nothing you didn't see nothing you did
you didn't see nothing alright let's
explore there's big Bamba licious juicy
Texas oh you mad look at this guy look
at this guy look at this guy
it'll mess with a booty bye oh god this
is scary yeah random holes in the ground
let's add those I appreciate it Thank
You Mojang yeah yeah yeah listen that
random holes in the ground listen what
are you get a life dude okay so this is
a proper one god damn look at the size
of this thing unfortunately it's the
same one as we found I thought it was a
different type for a second man Heil
taken all right here we go floor to with
all the teeth can you know it just flip
off dude I wish you could ride those
that'd be cool
oh mama seek that mamacita Conchita
you're cool we're cool yeah I'm gonna
take you is it good is it good what is
this band there
it's not good it's garbage I'll take the
gold though
come on garbage someone will pay for
this never seen a double chess in the
wild before except your mom's
yeah the old mazia oh god I almost dead
it's cool you're gonna need a lot more
to take down me buddy
yeah there's so many dead ends in this
and it sounds like my stomach is hungry
and I keep getting trolled yes there
they are found ya
give me go what what is this James
spectral arrow what am I gonna do with
change go okay more higgling banners
that don't snack I will take it I'm not
happy but I will accept it so cool look
from both angles love it love love love
love it
look how deep it goes though that I feel
like there has to be something else I'm
gonna do the forbidden whoo how you
doing
oh I want to ask I want interfere I mean
all right I think we hit the bottom whoa
so cool I love this law dead ends that
that has nothing here's gold yes fun it
oh all right I understand how these work
now time for me to leave let's find
another one up up and away
what is that is that another one I
almost dead for a clock worth it
they're all golden stuff curse of
vanishing what I almost thought what
that does I don't even know all right
let's keep looking guys what is this
whew okay
alright this is a different one I think
I think it looks different
hey hey hey hey I come from far land hey
hey hey hey this year
child hmm this your little bad bet would
be a shame if baby go Baba would be
shame you better trade me there's
another that God has so many temptations
I almost dead worth it though because I
got oh god this is getting ridiculous
how do I enter this thing I forgot it
the goal Oh should we start up here
maybe out this is unexplored territory I
don't know where the chests is and I
don't know where to go or this but I
will okay found it all right we got more
banners I don't need more banners band
there's this go away child this is
garbage
crying obsidian the only one crying here
is me can I shoot spectral arrows oh
dude that was sweet
freaking super died are you mad you mad
huh you mad
hail don't ever shoot back at me don't
damage the Dragonite stinky I'll take
you all out from a safe distance
Oh steady steady
oh yeah yet your goal yeah just get dirt
under mine in your oh it's a teleporter
Lee laughs ease
[Music]
I'm just wrong just wrong that's enough
of that that was fun
she do that again look at much XP I had
hey hey hey hey did I do something bad
oh no I hope I didn't do anything bad I
hate hurting people's feelings dude this
place is insane oh my god I don't know
where to go
forget the we found the goal I'm just
scared bang I thought yeah yeah yeah
look at that they mark it dumbasses
shouldn't mark it where you hide your
goal that's rule number one of gold
hiding learn to hide gold then you can
complain this is like a tower how are
you doing you okay mate it would seem
that you are absolutely dead what do we
got what do we got
I'm not afraid dead dead dead dead dead
dead dead you're dead you're dead you're
dead look at his knee I don't care I
don't care they came at me the child
came way too close
I was uncomfortable I felt attacked
so speed yes
I'm pretending I don't want this garbage
all right more I want more now now or
else more died huh you don't want that
are you huh you don't want more to died
huh no not like this I will not dead
like this I will not dead like this I
don't think so buddy I'm practicing
martial arts for 54 years I think I know
what I'm doing kung-fu Swedish dude
you're fast
I appreciate your speed but what you
lack is strength and big people hey look
at that
I'm ready for your flappers I'm ready
for your flappers huh we found another
one is that the same one big step yeah
it's the same one dang it it's so good
I'll keep two of them oh oh we found the
gold
yeah that's another one right there
never right I know it's not another
right that is to choke be quiet
who dares shoot at me in these times of
peace who goes there now they're
shooting each other
stinky aha
you need help Bern Bern
dang it I don't want no goddamn change
no magma cream I don't want that legs
give me your legs you're going lava and
say goodbye SM edge did not say goodbye
I know there's a spawner in one of these
I'm wondering how to find it that was so
cool oh my god
that was amazing that's the fastest
treasure ever mrs. Peter pie making a
return return to base
hello oh god hello hello hello did this
one spawn inside the ground what in the
world
whoa all right we got to be extra
SuperDuper careful here I don't like
this it's well lit though I gotta give
him no please don't hurt the Swedish
he's immune to arrows why won't these
those guys are tough I think this one is
different kind of hard to tell oh stop
it smote thee all right I will not hurt
them this time cuz I don't want to dead
yeah come on what do I do with this
maybe they're super important and I just
don't know oh my god Felix I can't
believe you I'm sorry they should make
it more clear like purple for epic
everyone knows that well this place is
garbage come on
have you guys heard of bridges my god
build them please oh I see another one
I see another one are you kidding me
what are you poor in poor town is this
poor town is that what this place called
a gold okay all right you piqued my
interest
I'll take it you flippin dead I hate you
you stink air run run run yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah cooked bacon come on come on I
can't help you now
he's done I was going to save him sorry
these two the same then or is this a
different one I mean I'm getting a lot
of different loot oh it is a different
one what the flipping Terrace tip
dipping in mob bling bleep it and my
bleep in my bleep my bleep I bleep a
this is a different one Gold cold cold
cold cold
no dude if Sven saw this he would be
like oh there they are what are they
doing why are you all squeezed in here
so weird oh my god what is happening
Loki want to blow them up let's do it
from a distance forgot how freaking fast
there that's what I thought that's what
I thought
dude that was cool I didn't mean to do
that
what are you looking at Pig why'd I have
to pick a fight with everyone what's
wrong with me if you don't deliver gold
you dead simple rules
all right Nazis just like that like
Superman god this place is creepy and
weird and I don't like what is this well
is this month that cannot be normal that
is not a normal spawn thing god I don't
have time for stink machine gun
alright alright let one of you live can
they hurt me well then you didn't you
could have been wrong you are their
children what come on this cannot be a
coincidence
oh it's it just a coincidence alright
fair it was a coincidence it looked cool
to be fair a lot of this looks very cool
I like the idea that you can jump into
lava at any point that's really cool
that's a comforting thought at all times
home sweet home alabama' that's right
thank you Alabama as always I will pay
my taxes one lump of coal as we agreed
on I think that's fair considering I
barely got anything from this see you on
the other side say how do you that
alright alright
ah this gate suck ja ja changmo sorry
I'm watching too many kdramas hey
everyone hey hey alright we got a lot of
gold a lot of gold look at this my
children look how rich I am bask in my
richness bet you wish you had this much
pudding doesn't didn't you didn't eat
that is a lot actually no damn God deal
I can see the Earth from here I mean
yeah should have jumped into pool I
didn't for some reason alright Sven you
get a the new Linkin Park album you get
a chain yeah yeah what do I do with the
chains what is this why did they add
this huh what's the point I know
that's right you're in jail now motherf
lapa where you belong you will never
escape Pierre see I can't even ask Oh
actually you are stuck yeah try and
escape try and escape do it
fine escape do it I dare you escape
escaped do it yeah you get an apple
Golden Apple I'm rarest item in the game
that's what I thought oh yeah let's
check out the banners how do I put those
up been there yeah
you will pay for this you never ever do
that again do you understand these
chains have spells on them from Wizards
and stuff yeah you never escaped shown
you don't talk to him do not talk to him
send come over here Sven stop stop you
don't speak to that person or how do I
use the banner and that's it I'm fine
you know what it's cool I like that
that's cool right that's cool right yeah
yeah
yeah yeah all right finally you're
against Megan you get an award at least
you get this dude you look good man dude
you look good man all right let's play
Lana Del Rey all right game was will the
demon can't escape from its prison in
the next episode we will find out will
the tower be glorious we will find out
will I find more nether right we will
find that thank you for watching in
there episode gently hit the like button
Sarat subscribe before for gang if
you're stealing gangers unsubscribe on
the stick of vision and that's it you
know in a world where science knows no
boundaries travel to land where no tuber
has been and explore never-before-seen
landscapes
[Music]
Bengston are extinct meet Mayan actors
ancestors who collect ancient items
rediscover your favorite scientifically
accurate dinos what will you create
you